you said that in some sense becoming an
adult means you take charge of your
emotions maybe never said that maybe I
just made that up
but in context of the mind what's the
role of emotion and what is it first of
all what is emotion was its role it's
several things so psychologists often
distinguish between emotion and feeling
and then commande parlance we don't
don't I think that in motion is a
configuration of the cognitive system
and that's especially true for the
lowest level for the affective state so
when you have an effect it's the
configuration of certain modulation
parameters like arousal valence your
your attentional focus whether it's wide
or narrow interception or extra
reception and so on and all these
parameters together put you in a certain
way to you relate with the environment
and to yourself and this is in some
sense and emotional configuration and
the more narrow sense an emotion is an
affective state it has an object and the
relevance of that object is given by
motivation and motivation is a bunch of
needs that are associated with rewards
things that give you pleasure and pain
and you don't actually act on your needs
you act on models of your needs because
when the pleasure and pain manifest it's
too late you've done everything but so
you act on expectations what will give
you a pleasure and pain and these are
your purposes the needs don't form a
hierarchy they just coexist and compete
and your organism is why brain has to
find it on dynamic homeostasis between
them but the purposes need to be
consistent so you basically can create a
story for your life and make plans and
so we organize them all into hierarchies
and there is not a unique solution for
this some people eat to make art and
other people regard to eat they might up
be end up doing the same things but they
cooperate in very different ways because
there are timid quotes are different and
vie cooperate based on shared purpose
everything else it is not cooperation on
shared purpose is transactional I don't
think I understood the last piece of the
cheating the homeostasis are you
distinguishing between the experience of
emotion and the expression of emotion of
course so the experience of emotion is a
feeling
and in the sense what you feel is an
appraisal that your perceptual system is
made of the situation at hand and it
makes this based on your motivation yes
and on the you are estimates not your
but of the subconscious geometric parts
of your mind that assess the situation
in the world with something like a
neural network and this neural network
is making itself known to the symbolic
parts of your mind to your conscious
attention by our mapping the them as
features into a space so what you will
feel about your emotion is a projection
usually enjoy your body map so might
feel anxiety in your solar plexus and
you might feel it as a contraction which
is all geometry right your body map is
this face that is always instantiate and
always available so it's a very obvious
cheat if your non-symbolic parts of your
brain try to talk to your symbolic parts
of your brain to map the feelings into
the body map and then you perceive them
as pleasant and unpleasant depending on
whether the appraisal has a negative or
positive valence and then you have
different features of them that give you
more knowledge about the nature of what
you're feeling so for instance when you
feel connected to other people you
typically feel this new chest region
around your heart and you feel this is
an expansive feeling in which you're
reaching out right and it's very
intuitive to encode it like this that's
why it's encoded like it's encoded
it's in color code it's a code in which
the non symbolic parts of your mind
talked with the symbolic ones and then
the expression of emotion is then the
final step that could be sort of
gestural or visual yeah so on that's
part of this MOOC is probably evolved as
part of an adversarial communication so
as soon as you started to observe the
facial expression and poster of others
to understand what emotional state they
are in others started to use this as
signalling and also to subvert your
model of their emotional state so we now
look at the inflections at the
difference between the standard face
that they're going to make in this
situation when you were at the funeral
everybody expects you to make a solemn
face but the solemn face doesn't express
whether you're said or not it just
expresses that you understand what face
you have to make it a funeral nobody
should know that you are Trump
triumphant so when you try to read the
emotion of another person you try to
look at the Delta but
it said a truly set expression and the
things that are animated mating this
face behind the curtain so the
interesting thing as so having done
these having done this podcast and the
video component one of the things I've
learned is that now I'm Russian and I
dad you don't know how to expression
motion on my face when I see that as
weakness but whatever the people look to
me after you say something they look to
my face - just to help them see how they
should feel about we said which is
fascinating because then they'll often
comment on why did you look bored or why
did you particularly enjoy that part or
why did you whatever it's a kind of
interesting it makes me cognizant of on
part like you're basically saying a
bunch of brilliant things but I am part
of the play the year of the key actor
and by making my facial expressions and
then do and therefore telling the
narrative of what the big like the big
point is which is fascinating makes me
makes it cognizant that I'm supposed to
be making facial expressions even this
conversation is hard because my
preference would be to wear a mask with
sunglasses to where I could just listen
yes which is understand this because
it's intrusive to interact with others
this way and basically Eastern European
society have a taboo against that and
especially Russia the further you go to
the east and in the US it's the opposite
you are expected to be hyper animated in
your face and you're also expected to
show positive effect yes and if you show
positive effect without a good reason
in Russia they people will think you are
a stupid and sophisticated person
exactly and here positive effect with
our reason goes either appreciate or
goes unnoticed no it's the default it's
being expected everything is amazing
have you seen these lego movie no there
was a diagram where somebody gave the
appraisals that exist in the US and
Russia so you have your black curve and
and the lower 10% in u.s. yeah are it's
a good start
about the lowest 10% is it's amazing
it's amazing and for Russians yeah
everything below the top 10% is it's
terrible and then everything except the
top percent is I don't like it and the
10% is even so yeah it's funny but it's
kind of true no yeah there's a deeper
aspect to this it's also how we
construct meaning in the u.s. usually
you focus on the positive aspects and
you just suppress the negative aspects
and and our Eastern European traditions
we emphasize the fact that if you hold
something above the waterline you also
need to put something below the
waterline because existence by itself is
best neutral right that's the basic
intuition if at best neutral yes or he's
just suffering the default there are
moments of beauty but these moments of
beauty are in is inextricably linked to
the reality of suffering and to not
acknowledge the reality of suffering
means that you are really stupid unaware
of the fact that basically every
conscious being spends most of the time
suffering yeah you just summarized the
ethos of the Eastern Europe yeah most of
life is suffering with the occasional
moments of beauty and if your facial
expressions don't acknowledge the
abundance of suffering in the world and
in existence itself then you must be an
idiot it's an interesting thing when you
raise children in the US and you in some
sense preserve the identity of the
intellectual and cultural traditions
that are embedded in your own families
and your daughter asks you about Arielle
the mermaid
yeah and ask you why is Aria not allowed
to play with the humans and you tell her
the truth she was a siren 70 people you
don't play with your does not end well
and then you tell her the original story
which is not the one by Anderson which
is the romantic one and there's a much
darker one using a story what happened
so when Dean is a mermaid or a water
woman she lives on ground off a river
and she meets this prince and there fall
enough and the prince really really
wants to be with her and she says okay
but the deal is you cannot have any
other woman if you marry somebody else
even though you cannot be with me
because obviously you cannot breathe and
the water and I have other things to do
then managing your kingdom busier up
here you will die and eventually after a
few years he falls and off with some
princess and marries her and she shows
up and quietly goes into his chamber and
nobody is able to stop her or willing to
do so because she is fierce and she
comes quietly and said out of his
chamber and they asked her what has
happened what did you do when she said I
kissed him to death all done and if you
know the end isn't story right in the
end isn't story the mermaid is playing
with this prince that she saves and she
falls on that with him and she cannot
live out there so she is giving up her
voice and her tail for a human-like
appearance so she can walk among the
humans but this guy does not recognize
that she is the one that you would marry
instead he marries somebody who has a
kingdom and economical and political
relationships to his own kingdom and so
on as he shoots quite tragic she dies
yeah so yeah instead Disney The Little
Mermaid story has a little bit of her
happy ending that's the Western that's
the American Way my own problem is
justice of course that I read Oscar
Wilde before I read the other things so
I mean doctrine ate it inoculated with
this Romanticism and I think that the
mermaid is right you sacrifice your life
for romantic love that's what you do
because if you are confronted with
either serving the Machine and doing the
the obviously right thing under the
economic and social and all other
inhuman incentives that's wrong you
should follow your heart
you